APRIL EIGHTEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING.
PLEASE NOTE FOR TODAY ONLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY WILL
REPLACE AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN
EGGMAN.
AND MISTER MULLIN WILL REPLACE.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO WHEN THEY'RE HERE WE CAN
WELCOME THEM.
NOTING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
WILL GO HEAD AND EYES START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
MR MEDINA. LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE
NUMBER ONE.
SO I SEE HERE GONNA PRESENT ON
YOUR SUSPENSE BILL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
BUSTER SEAT ME. IF YOU WILL.
TODAY OUR PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
A BILL THAT WILL ADD A COURSE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES.
TO MAKE AT A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
BEGINNING IN THE SCHOOL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR.
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN SCHOOL YEAR.
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR STUDENTS WERE
ENROLLED IN ETHNIC STUDIES
CLASSES.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. UP
FROM EIGHT THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT. AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN.
THE CURRICULUM IS TO BE ADOPTED
BY MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY.
THERE ARE SEVERAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE ALREADY MADE
ETHNIC STUDIES THAT.
A COOK. OF REQUIREMENT FOR
GRADUATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
I THINK IF ARE THERE ANY.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS AND.
GOOD MORNING THERESA MACHADO
FROM COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE NO
FIVE.
I THINK YOU ARE LEADING
QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MR MEDINA YOU
LIKE CLOSE DISCUSS ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
QUICK AND EASY.
MISTER STONE.
ACCURATE NEXT.
WE'LL BE PRESENTING ON AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY NINE IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE GET A
QUORUM HERE. BUT YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU SO THIS BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS. THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO DO THE TRANSFER IS
THAT IT DOES WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE YOURSELF
HAVE ONE OF THE BILLS THEY TEND
TO ROLL THROUGH ON CONSENT.
AND.
GIVING THEM THE AUTHORITY TO DO
THESE TRANSFERS JUST MAKES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SENSE HE'S
A TRANSFERS TO GO GENERALLY TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
TO PUT PROPERTY IN THE PUBLIC
TRUST AND WE'VE ENSURED THAT
THEY WILL THEY CREATE A WEBSITE
SO THAT EVERYTHING THAT THEY'RE
DOING ITS TRANSPARENT AVAILABLE
THE PUBLIC AND AVAILABLE FOR US
TO SEE. THAT'S ALL THE BILL DOES
LONG TERM IT SHOULD SAVE THE
STATE MONEY AND I ASK FOR YOUR
ALBUMS.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
YES JERRY PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WERE SPONSORING THIS
LEGISLATION AND AGREE WITH US ON
THE MEMBER THAT IT WILL SAVE THE
STATE MONEY AND IT'S A VERY
COMMONSENSE HOPEFUL MEASURE THAT
WE FULLY SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THAT WE WOULD KNOW MINIMAL US.
MINIMAL COST SAVINGS FROM THIS
MEASURE.
I THINK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
I HAVE ONE.
IT'S ONE MAKE SURE.
.
IF FOR SOME REASON THERE WAS.
TRANSACTION TAKING PLACE THAT
MAY BE THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT
AGREE WITH THEY COULD STILL
INTERVENE LEGISLATIVELY IS THAT
CORRECT IT'S.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
NO THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE WILL TAKE THAT UP
ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
MISTER STONE.
IT LOOKS LIKE NEXT WEEK MISTER.
CHOI.
MISTER CHOI A. S. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE GOING AWAY
PRESENTATION ON A A. B. NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE. CENTS ON CONSENT
AND THAT MEANS HE'LL BE
PRESENTING ON A. B. NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE WHICH IS.
ON SUSPENSE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. MADAM. CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
AB.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE AB NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE INCREASES SOFT FREEDOM
OF CHOICE OF FOR STUDENTS.
BYOBB PREVENTING COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES SO FROM REQUIRING
THE PURCHASE OF A METER PLANNED
SITE AS A CONDITION OF A LIVING.
IN KNOCKED CAMPUS A PROVIDED A
HOUSING.
ADDITIONALLY INVEST IS SOUGHT
WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED TO US
SEPARATE.
THE COST OF A CAMPUS PROVIDED A
MEALS MERE PLAN SITE AND NOT
HOUSING PLANS SO ON THEIR CAMPUS
WEBSITES
AND THE LITERATURE. TO INCREASE
THE FINANCIAL TRANSPARENCY.
THIS YEAR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE THE CURRENT
COST OF A ROOM AND BOARD. ARE IN
ON ONE CAMPUS SO TRIP FOR
OCCUPANCY ROOM WITH THE METER
PLAZA POOREST ON YOU ONLY
THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SOME UNIVERSITY ASSISTANT
REQUIRE FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
TRANSFER STUDENTS UP TO PURCHASE
IMMEDIATE PLANS.
EVEN IF FIVE YOU HOUSING
UNICYCLE THEY BELIEVE IN THE
WHOLE FOR COOKING AMENITIES.
OVER THE PAST DECADE THE AVERAGE
WAR. APPOINTEE MIANO SAW.
BUT WE'VE GOT. AT THE FOUR YEAR
COLLEGES SAW HAS SO RECENT FORTY
SIX PERCENT.
TWO FOUR THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
TWO DOLLARS SO FOR TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND A FIFTEEN.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR EDUCATION STATISTICS.
THIS A REQUIREMENT OF TO
PURCHASE TO A MERE PLAN
ELIMINATES THOSE POSH SHOULDN'T
TOYS SUCKED IN DETERMINING WHAT
THE WOULD BE MORE ECONOMIC CALL
A FOR THE OUR WELL BEING.
BY CONNECTING OUR EIGHTIES
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE NOW WE ENSURE
TOYS AND THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
STUDENTS ARE AND THAT YOUR
PARENTS. TO BETTER AFFORD TO
COLLEGE I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR AYE.
I THINK YOU ARE THERE ANY
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
REDUCED MEAL PLAN REVENUES FOR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES FOR
EXAMPLE IF TEN PERCENT OF THE
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS LIVING IN
ON CAMPUS HOUSING AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
WERE TO FORGO A MEAL PLAN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD FOREGO
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REVENUE.
IRATE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS SEEN
NINE THIS BILL DOES MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE.
CHOI LATER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO IS THERE ANY.
WHICH I CLOSE.
I ASK FOR YOUR I'VE WE'RE GOING
TO SUPPORT THEM AND THOUGH WE
PASS ON TO THE ASSEMBLY. THANK
YOU.
I DO WHEN AT THAT WE HAVE NO
AUTHORS IN THE.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IF
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO COME DOWN
PERCENT NOW WOULD BE A GOOD
TIME.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BIGELOW PRESIDENT BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH HERE.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CHAO.
MCCARTY.
PHONE.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE. MULLIN. BREATH
.
HEARING.
I WOULD THINK YOU.
AB TWENTY THREE SIX NINE WOULD
CRACKDOWN APPROACHING A MARINE
PROTECTED AREAS BY COMMERCIAL
FISHING OPERATIONS BY INCREASING
THE PENALTIES INCLUDING FINES
FOR POACHING BY COMMERCIAL. AND
T. AN MPA.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE
.
MATT BROAD.
FROM BROWNING GUESS MEN ARE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE SPORT
FISHING CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU
.
NO FILE.
IF ACCEPTED THEM
.
THINK YOU'RE I SEE WE HAVE SOME.
AUTHOR'S NOW IN THE AUDIENCE WE
WILL GO ON TO.
MISTER COOPER.
MINISTER COOPER.
I'M ASSUMING AWAY PRESENTATION
ON AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTEEN AS
IT'S ON CONSENT AND WILL BE
PRESENTING ON A. B. TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY WITH THEIR.
HE MAY PROCEED BUT YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS LAST YEAR LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED AB ONE NINETEEN.
REQUIRE ALL NEW PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
BE PROVIDED IN ORIENTATION.
A BETWEEN I SEVENTY WITH SIMPLY
CLARIFY THAT NOTICE OF NEW
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION SHOULD BE
ONLY PROVIDED TO THE NEW
EMPLOYEES.
MANAGEMENT IN THE EXCLUSIVE
REPRESENTATIVE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY GOALS
EMPLOYEES AND MANAGEMENT.
A RECENT REPORT BY US BUREAU OF
JUSTICE STATISTICS.
FOUNDED THE RATE OF WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE
THREE TIMES HIGHER.
THE PUBLIC SECTOR IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AYE URGING AYE VOTE TO
PROTECT NEW PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO
WERE TENDING THEIR ORIENTATION.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER S..
A SECOND BY MISC CARILLO.
EITHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
POINTING AT SOME.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
NO FILE.
ARE THERE QUESTIONS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
I MISTER COOPER THAT BILLS ON
CALL.
ONCE WE ENOUGH NUMBERS HERE BUT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT UP WE HAVE.
.
MR.
GRAYSON IT LOOKS LIKE WOULD BE
NEXT.
MR GRAYSON YOU PRISON AND AB
THREE ZERO ZERO TWO IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THOUSAND TO
WHICH IS A PROACTIVE MEASURE
THAT PROVIDES HELPFUL RESOURCES
AND INFORMATION TO BUSINESS
OWNERS. TO INCREASE THEIR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE AMERICAN
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
EIGHTY A AND RELATED LAWS AND
REGULATIONS TO GUARANTEE EQUAL
ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND I AGREE. WITH
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT
FISCAL COST SHOULD BE NEGLIGIBLE
BECAUSE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ISSUING THE BUILDING PERMITS CAN
RECOVER COSTS THROUGH THE
PERMITTING FEES.
THEREFORE WE BELIEVE THERE'S
KNOW REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
BEING CREATED BY THIS
LEGISLATION AND FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY THAT'S
WHAT I.
THANK YOU.
THAT HAS MUCH BY MISS KOREA ANY
SECOND BY MISS RADIUS.
.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOVA.
MISTRESS.
I JUST WANT THINK YOU DID IT
OFTENTIMES WE'RE LOOKING AT.
.
CHANGING LAWS FOR THINGS THAT
MAY GO WRONG IN THE FUTURE AND
THIS IS A VERY PROACTIVE BILL
THAT ALLOWS.
THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO START A
BUSINESS TO KNOW EVERYTHING THEY
NEED TO KNOW BEFORE THE OPEN THE
BUSINESS SO THEY CAN BE EIGHT
ADA COMPLIANT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
IT BACK ANOTHER.
THANK YOU MISTER GRACE AND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT LAST FOREVER AND THAT
WILL BE PLACED ON CALM AND WE
WILL TAKE CARE BUT SINCE WE GET
A BREAK HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THINK YOU KNOW.
NEXT IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU HAVE
THREE BILLS AYE I'M ASSUMING
YOU'RE GOING AWAY PRESENTATION
ON TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN WHICH
GOES ON SUSPENSE IN TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO WHICH IS ON CONSENT
WHICH MEANS YOU ARE PRESENTING
ON A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO
WHICH ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO LOW IT AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO WOULD ALLOW
WERE LINED STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA EXTEND.
TRANSITIONAL CAO FRESH BENEFITS
TO FAMILIES LEAVING STATE AND
LOCALLY FUNDED CASH ASSISTED
PROGRAMS UPON CERTIFICATION BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
TWO WOULD MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE WAY THAT THE CAL
FRESH EMPLOYMENT. AND TRAINING
PROGRAM FUNDS MAY BE USED AN
EXPANSIVE ABOVE INDIVIDUALS THAT
COUNTIES MAY SIR THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP WITH EMPLOYMENT
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT THIS BILL ADDS NEDUM
NEGLIGIBLE COST TO DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND IT CHANGES
ARE CLARIFYING AND CONSISTENT
WITH CURRENT PRACTICE.
THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO ME BY
THE HUNGER ACTION LOS ANGELES
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IF ANY
QUESTIONS
THE JESSICA BARTHOLOMEW FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW RESPECT
LAST WEEK I'VE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER SINCE PART
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JUST ABOUT THE
WITH WHAT'S WRITTEN ON LAW AND
POVERTY A SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. JUST TO REINFORCE
THAT.
ENDING HUNGER IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARD
SUPPORTING EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING HUNGER IT'S
HARD TO GO TO WORK IT'S HARD TO
FIND A JOB IT'S HARD TO KEEP THE
JOB WHEN YOU'RE HUNGRY.
AND AND RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT.
HUNGER UNDERMINES WORK NOT ONLY
FOR ADULTS WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
WORK IN FINDING AND FINDING WORK
BUT ALSO.
.
ALSO BECAUSE OF THEIR CHILDREN
REMARKS ARE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
HUNGER AND BE LESS OF A
SUCCESSFUL IN SCHOOL AND FINALLY
BECAUSE US THAT BENEFITS. THE
ONLY HOPE PEOPLE WHO.
ARE HUNGRY TO PREVENT HUNGER
BUT ALSO SUPPORT THE ECONOMY.
EVERY BILLION DOLLARS IT'S NOT
BENEFITS RESULTS IN AS MANY AS
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND JOBS IN AN
ECONOMY LIKE OURS IT'S THAT
RELIES ON FOOD.
GROWTH AND.
PRODUCTION
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS COMMITTEE
THINKING.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NO FILE.
WE'VE A MOTION BY MISS KOREA ON
A SECOND BY A MYSTERIOUS.
.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL รณ I'M
SORRY AREA JUMPED THE GUN THERE
WE HAVE A QUESTION.
TO THE AUTHOR.
I HEARD THE WORDS ABOUT.
NEEDING TO HELP IN FEE.
AND ALL THAT BUT A CONCERN I
HAVE IS.
THE FACT THAT YOU GET.
ALSO PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET.
CELL PHONES AND THE LIKE.
THAT CAN BE AN OPEN DOOR POLICY
THAT'S GOING TO.
LIMIT SOME OF THE SUCCESS
DEFEATING THOSE WHO ARE MOST IN
NEED OF. JUST SUBSTANCE.
CAN YOU LOOK AT THAT IS YOUR
BILL. CONTINUES MOVING FORWARD
ABOUT MAYBE ELIMINATING THAT
PORTION.
OR LIMITING THAT.
COMPONENT CERTAIN COUNTIES ARE
DOING AT THIS THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN RIGHT NOW WILL ALLOW ALL
COUNTIES.
AND IT WILL BE AN ADDED COST.
SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD. WITH
WOULD DEFINITELY DEFINITELY ONE
INHIBIT ANYBODY FROM ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT UP AND AS IT MOVES
FORWARD WILL WORK WITH THE DAWN
SUPPORTERS AND WITH THE
COUNTIES.
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT DOESN'T BECOME AN
IMPEDIMENT.
THANK YOUNG AND AND THAT.
WE'LL GO ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAU.
I SEE WE'RE GONNA WAVED.
YOUR CONCEPTUAL AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY AND PRESENT ON AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S RIGHT
THANK YOU.
WHEN CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES ARE
CARRILLO ALREADY PROHIBITS
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FROM
INTERFERING WITH PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WHILE EXERCISING THEIR
RIGHT TO HAVE UNION
REPRESENTATION. BUT THIS
PROTECTION AT THIS TIME DOES NOT
EXTEND TO PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYEES
AND THE POSSIBILITY OF A LOOP
HOLE ARE THAT AN EMPLOYER COULD
TRY TO CONVINCE A PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYEE. NOT TO BECOME A UNION
MEMBER OUT DURING THE JOB
INTERVIEW PROCESS AND THROUGH
THE THREAT OF NOT RECEIVING A
JOB.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WOULD CLOSE A SIMPLE.
AND AS HE ANNOUNCES NOTES THERE
SHOULD NOT BE AN ADDITIONAL COST
OF STATE WITH THAT RISK.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER AS A
SECOND BY MISS.
CREO.
.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT SHOW CAST OF
THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION MASRI AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE IN SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I THINK IT'S GREAT
BILL IF IT PROCEEDS TODAY I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS E. CO
AUTHOR PLUS I WOULD BE HAPPY
FLAT AND.
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECT ANSWER SUPPORT AND THAT
WILL GO ON BECAUSE I THINK IF
YOU.
MISS CAMBIADO.
I SEE THAT YOU'RE WAVING
PRESENTATION ON YOUR TWO BILLS
THAT I CAN GO ON SUSPENSE YOU'RE
GONNA PRESENT ON AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE WHICH ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE WILL
ADD MIGRANT STUDENTS. TO
EXISTING LAW SO THAT THEY CAN
READ RECEIVE PARTIAL OR FULL
CREDIT FOR WORK COMPLETED IN
ANOTHER SCHOOL. AND BE EXEMPT
FROM LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT
COURSEWORK REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
ADDITIONAL TO THE STATE
REQUIREMENTS. THAT IF A STUDENT
CANNOT REASONABLY MEET THEM IN
TIME FOR HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
SO CURRENT LAW PROVIDES THESE
RIGHTS TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS FOR IN FOSTER CARE WERE
CHILDREN OF MILITARY FAMILIES.
WHO ARE?
INVOLVED IN THE JUVENILE COURT
SYSTEM.
AS YOU KNOW STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT STUDENT MOBILITY HAS
NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON STUDENT
SUCCESS INCLUDING. TESTERS
WRITTEN TEST SCORES RETENTION
AND HIGH SCHOOL COMPLETION THIS
IS LONG OVERDUE.
IT'S EIGHT THAT IT'S QUITE
FRANKLY I WAS KIND OF SHOCKED TO
FIND OUT THE MIGRANT STUDENTS
STUDENTS ARE NOT TREATED THE
SAME AS OTHER STUDENTS THAT HAVE
HIGH MOBILITY ISSUES WERE
UNRELATED TO THEIR. PERSONAL
LIFE EXPERIENCES AND OP
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS
INSPIRED.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS TAKE SOME A
SHOT I WITH COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTRESS IN
A SECOND BY MISS CREO. I.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
AND WE WILL THAT VOTE. THAT BILL
IS ON CALL WILL TAKE IT UP
THINKERS AND HOPEFULLY THANK
YOU.
MR ACOSTA.
MISTER KANSI OF THREE BILLS I
ASSUME YOU'LL WE A PRESENTATION
ON THOSE THAT ARE GOING TO
SUSPEND CENTER GOING TO PRESENT
ON AB TWENTY NINETY SEVEN WHICH
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMNDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
RANDY.
.
VERY BRIEFLY AND AND TWENTY
TAMMY I'M LEGISLATION ASIDE TO
CREATE THE CORPORATE STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM. THAT CREATES A THAT
REQUIRES IN THE PUBLIC.
AND CHAIR.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
THE SECOND BY MISTER
FATE WILL THEN ALL A CUT TO THE
CHASE AB TWENTY NINETY SEVEN
CHANGES THE DATA THE SUBMISSION
OF THE ANNUAL PORT FROM JULY
FIRST TO SEPTEMBER FIRST. IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE TIME
TO GATHER THE DATA DRAFT REPORT
PROVIDED ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
FEEDBACK AND THEN SUBMIT IT TO
CAL RECYCLE AS IS REQUIRED BY
LAW. THE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
SIXTY DAYS IS JUST TOO WILL
SIMPLY ALLOW FOR ADEQUATE
PREPARATION REVIEW FOR THE PLAN
BEFORE SEMITIC OUR CYCLE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES THE
SECRETE NO ADDITIONAL STATE
COSTS. ARE EXPECT LESSER AYE
VOTE AND SO MANY POLITICS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE SPOTS OF THE
CARPET RUG INSTITUTE IN CASE YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR IF YOU
THINK WE COME. THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT ABOUT THAT WE HAVE TO THE
CARPET RUG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
AND ANY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
ACOSTA YOU A WIN THE PRIZE IN
YOUR VOTE YOUR BILL IS THE FIRST
TO GET OUT TODAY.
ON IN A ROLL CALL WITH MR BLOOM
NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK FOR
TOUGH.
A GREAT IF WE GOT SOME
DEMOCRATIC.
MEMBERS DOWN TO GET SOME OTHER
VOTES OUT.
THINK.
THANK YOU FOR SHOWING UP TO
SPEED.
I I I THINK I. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS BILLS
MISTER CHALLEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SIX ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX WILL
ENSURE THAT THE SENDER SO FALSE
AND DECEPTIVE US SPAM EMAILS ARE
HELD LIABLE. FOR THEIR UNLAWFUL
CONDUCT.
IT WILL ALSO EXPAND WHAT IS
CONSIDER FALSE AND DECEPTIVE
CONTENT AND FINALLY ENABLE
COURTS TO ORDER INJUNCTIONS THAT
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
WE HAVE MOTION BY MISTER IS THE
SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN.
ARE THERE SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
TERRACE MACHADO COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EITHER ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOVA.
THANK YOU. I AT MISTER OBERNOLTE
IS HERE QUESTION OF THE COMMAND
CHAIR. LIVE BIG SUPPORTER WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
I CONTINUE TO HOPE THAT YOU WILL
WORK ON THE SECTIONS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT IN PRIVACY THE.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO IS SECTION
OF THE BILL ARE YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK I THINK THAT'S A COMMON
PRACTICE I DON'T THINK THAT'S
DECEPTIVE AND I.
HOPE YOU CONSIDER TAKING THAT
OUT ALSO I THINK THAT YOU NEED
TO DO SOME MORE WORK ON
CLARIFYING WHAT IT MEANS TO SAY
FREE. SINCE YOU COULD SAY SUGAR
FREE IN THE SUBJECT LINE OF AN
EMAIL IT WOULD BE A VIOLATION OF
THE BILL WHICH I DON'T THINK IS
YOUR INTENT. WILL DO JUST THAT
IN FACT THAT WE GONNA JUST TO
REMOVE THE PROVISION REGARDING
FREE FROM THE BILL ON THE
COUNTER AND LOOKED INTO THE
HOMELESS AS WELL. OKAY THAT
REALIZE YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
CNN MIKE WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE
MAZAR I ASK FOR SUPPORT. I'D
SEEN AS WE GET ANOTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBER DOWN WE WILL TAKE THAT UP
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU.
IT'S FRIEDMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
MYSTERY MAN I ASSUME YOU ARE
GOING TO WAY PRESENTATION ON AB
TWO SIX SIX THREE WHICH GOES ON
SUSPENSE NOT I'M SURE I WOULD
NEVER WASTE IS COMMITTEES TIME
BY PRESENTING A SHOW ON
SUSPENSE.
YOU ARE A MODEL PRESENTER. THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
BUT YOU WILL HAVE TO PRESENT AB
TWO TWO TWO SEVEN IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO THEIR PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN
MOTORCYCLING TAX. IN ORDER TO
UPDATE A PROCESS SIMILAR TO THE
FEDERAL PROCESS FOR NEW CAR
SALES BY WHICH MOTORCYCLE
MANUFACTURERS AND DEALERS
PROVIDE MORE ROBUST INFORMATION
ON THE MOTORCYCLE HANG TAG
PRICE.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN
ENSURES THAT THE PRICE TAG ON
MOTORCYCLES IS CLEAR TO THE
CONSUMER BY INCLUDING THE
MANUFACTURER'S SUGGESTED PRICE
BEEN NUMBER AND THE SUPPLEMENTAL
ADD ON'S A DEALER MAY INCLUDE.
THIS PRICING MODEL IS MANDATED
ON THE WIND CHILL OF NEW CARS
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA IN THE FORM
OF THE MON RONI.
MON RONI STICKER AND SHOULD BE
UNIFORM FOR NEW MOTORCYCLES SOLD
IN CALIFORNIA AS THE ANALYSIS
STATES THIS MEASURE ADDS ONLY
MINOR CASA DMB TO UPDATE AND
DISTRIBUTE INFORMATION AS THE
DMV HAS ALREADY BEEN PROCESS IN
THIS PRICE TAG SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SEVEN ADDS ONLY MINOR
ADDITIONS TO THEIR REVIEW
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AYE ARE THERE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THREE JAMES LUMBAR
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE
DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
IT'S CLEAR THAT WE WOULD JUST
LIKE TO HAVE THE VIN NUMBER ON
THE HANG TAG THAT'S THE ONLY
CHANGE THAT ALLOWS US WHEN WE
GET OUR. MOTORCYCLES IN CRATES
TO AND CRATE THEM YOU HAVE A
FLOOR FULL OF THE MEAN YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
TAG GOES ON THE PROPER
MOTORCYCLE FOR IDENTIFICATION
IT'S BEEN IN PRACTICE FOR.
SEVEN FORTY YEARS BUT THE
DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES
HAD NOT IMPLEMENTED THIS PLAN
AND THEY ARE NOW DOING IT UPON
RENEWAL BY MANUFACTURERS MERGER
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER.
SUPPORTERS.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
AND FINANCE NO FILE.
BOTH THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO
SECOND BABY. WAS AT MR CHOW.
THANK YOU.
.
WE CHECKED BECAUSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
THINK YOU AND I GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR PEROT AND MR
FUNG NOT VOTING.
I THINK YOU.
ALRIGHT.
WE CAN TAKE IT AM I DO ACCEPT A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I AM SEARCHING WE LIKE TO READ
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE EIGHTEEN
OH FIVE NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE
NINETEEN SIXTY TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FORTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
FORTY SIX TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT. TWENTY TO SEVENTY TWENTY
TO EIGHTY ONE TWENTY THREE
NINETY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR SIXTY NINE
TWENTY FOUR NINETY TWENTY FIVE
SIXTEEN TWENTY BY THIRTY TO.
FORTY FIVE FORTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY FOUR TWENTY SIX FORTY
SIX.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT OH ONE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE SEVENTEEN TWENTY
NINE NINETY THIRTY FORTY THREE
AND THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE.
LEYVA MOTION OF BY MISTER
BIGELOW TO SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE ON THE CONSENT COUNTER
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
AND WE NOW CAN TAKE UP.
AND IT SOME ADDITIONAL BILLS IF
I CAN GET A MOTION ON AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY NINE THESE ALL HAVE
MOTIONS I'M SORRY. LET ME
DISPENSE. THE FOLLOWING BILLS AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY NINE.
OKAY. THINK IT'S OUT OF THE ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL AB
THREE THOUSAND AND TWO. THAT
GETS OUT.
WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
AND MISTER BIGELOW VOTING AYE AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO JONES SAWYER
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN CHAIR THAT
IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FORTY ONE COVER YET ALL.
AND THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING A MISTER
BIGELOW VOTING I. A. B. TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SIX MISTER CHAO THE
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH
MR OBERNOLTE VOTING AYE AYE.
WE ARE ALL CAUGHT UP IN IF.
WE CAN GET MISTER RODRIGUEZ A
MR MCCARTY HERE WE COULD FINISH
UP IN THE MEANTIME I'M SECRETARY
pBEING MOVED TO SUSPENSE FILE.
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN SIXTY TO
EIGHTEEN OR FOR EIGHTEEN NINETY
FIVE NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO TWENTY
THIRTY TO TWENTY FORTY ONE.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FOUR THREE TO FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWO SIXTY NINE. THREE TWO
SEVENTY TWO TWENTY TWO NINETY
TWENTY TWO NINETY FOUR TWENTY
THREE OR FOUR. THREE THREE OR
SIX TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN.
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SIX TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
FOUR TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN. TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE NINETY. THREE
SIX OH SEVEN TWENTY SIX FIFTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE
TWENTY SEVEN OH ONE TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY SIX.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO TWENTY
EIGHT OH FOUR TWENTY EIGHT.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN
TWENTY NINE FIFTY THREE TWENTY
NINE SIXTY THREE TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SIX THIRTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN AND THIRTY ONE TWENTY.
IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON
ANY OF THOSE BILLS THAT WERE
MADE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
WHERE THERE IS NO PRESENTATION
YOU CAN COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE NOW AND STATE YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION?
ROB WHITE ARP.
WIN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
FOR THE VETERANS AMOCO WORKBENCH
AND MYSELF.
SO A A RP IS A STRONG SUPPORT OF
TWENTY SIX OH SEVEN. FIVE EIGHT
THANK HIM.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE OH FOR.
AND ON THE HALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
SIX.
THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES.
WE IT IF.
WE DISPENSE OF A BILL THAT DID
NOT HAVE A MOTION ON AT.
SO WE CAN GO BACK TO AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY NINE THAT WAS A STONE
BUILT I'VE A MOTION.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BONTA
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON AND
THAT GETS OUT ON THE ROLL CALL.
IS THERE.
WE ARE NOW WAITING ON MR
MCCARTY MISTER RODRIGUEZ WHERE
FINAL.
.
PRESENTERS I KNOW MISTER
RODRIGUEZ IS IN COMMITTEE BUT
HOPEFULLY.
SOMEBODY.
CONNECTEM
MR I'M I'M GONNA PRESENT MR
MCCARTY SPILL.
WITCHES AB TWENTY TWO TEN
.
AND CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGAN ON AB TWENTY TWO TEN
REPRESENTING MR MCCARTY.
AB TWENTY TWO TEN IS A CLEAN UP
BILL.
FROM LAST NEW THOUGH.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES HERE I'D
LOVE THAT.
THERE IS.
WOULD.
WORK LIKE.
CHAIR MEMBERS RJ SAID A MONTH
ASSEMBLY HAVE INTERNATIONAL
RESCUE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OPPOSITION.
HARTMAN OF FINANCE NO FILE NO
FILE. ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
S. GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
YOU VERY MUCH.
MR PEROT IS VOTING.
SO WE'RE WAITING FOR MR
RODRIGUEZ.
SO.
ON THE LAST BILL.
THE RECORD WILL REFLECT MISTER
GALLAGHER IS NOT VOTING
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS WERE WAITING ON
THIS RODRIGUEZ TO FINISH UP HIS
TESTIMONY NO. DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE
.
IF MR RODRIGUEZ IS STAFF COULD
BE NOTIFIED THAT MISTER BIGELOW
IS GOING TO PRESENT HIS DO PASS
EL.
WHICH IS AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
SIX.
SO HE DOES NOT NEED TO COME
DOWN.
MISTER BIGELOW.
THEY'RE REPRESENTING DIFFERENT.
PLEASURE AND HONOR WITH BELL.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BONTA
SECOND FIVE MISS RADIUS
WHICH I PROCEED.
I'M NOT SURE HAVE ENOUGH
WITNESSES FOR EVERYONE'S
ENTERTAINMENT TODAY BUT I'M SURE
YOU CAN ASK.
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE PRESENT
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
IF NOT.
I WE CORDIALLY AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOU TO USE THIS AS MY
CLOTHES AND THANK THE AUTHOR IN
A SECOND MAKER OF THE SECOND.
AND OKAY ARE THEIR KNEES
SUPPORTERS IN THE AUDIENCE.
ANY OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THIS BILL WILL NOT RESULT IN AND
GET IN ANY ADDITIONAL COST OF
THE STATE.
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
INCREASE HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS FOR
NON SAFETY MEMBERS. AS A RESULT
OF MORE SAFETY EMPLOYEES.
IGRATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY
HEALTH PLANS FOR CALPERS HEALTH
BENEFIT.
HEALTH PLANS.
THIS WILL ADVERSELY IMPACT THE
RISK POOL THE CALPERS UTILIZES
GENEGO SHAPE RATE WITH
PROVIDERS.
ACCORDING TO CALPERS
IMPLEMENTING THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL WILL NOT OF ANY
PROGRAMMATIC. OR FISCAL IMPACT
AND CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF FINISH STRAIGHT OF
OPERATIONS.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
CNN MISTER BIGELOW. AS YOU CAN
SEE MADAM CHAIR THIS WILL HAVE A
POSITIVE OUTCOME FOR THE PEOPLE
WE ALL SERVE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIFE.
THANK YOU AND I GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
BIGELOW AND I'M SURE MISTER
RODRIQUEZ THINKS YOU AS WELL.
I'M THAT CONCLUDES OUR
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR AN
ADDITIONAL.
FIVE MINUTES TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY MESSY MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
COME TO REGISTER THEIR VOTES.
THAT.
WOULD BE MR MCCARTY ARE MISTER
MULLIN HORRIBLE SUBSTITUTES
TODAY.
WE WILL AND MISTER GARCIA.
WE WILL WAIT FOR FIVE MINUTES
C. M. MISTER MULLIN.
A FEW MUAMMAR.
LISTER STAFF WANTS TO TELL ME
THEY NEED MORE
I I'M GOING TO AND CLOSE DOWN
THE HEARING